good is cleaning cathartic for you like
why i like the notion that something is
not right and i have the power to make
it right
do your sons like what kind of stains do
they create
generic i mean honestly permanent marker
is something that gets
everywhere usually it's my fault but
they participate sometimes as well all
right so
we have decided to take the hydrogen
peroxide
route here at the show today
now here's the good news i have a fail
safe
so i don't want to bury the lead and and
and make this too
comfortable for anyone also i'm loving
this
pouring situation my hydrogen peroxide
has just the big opening this is like
yeah this is so fancy do you know what i
have that i'm really into a hydrogen
peroxide that has a spray okay that's
amazing this is what gets me that's
amazing so we let the peroxide sit for a
second there it is hydrogen peroxide is
a new tool i feel like i just made it
worse i just made it worse
does it have to get worse before it gets
better
[Applause]
is the fail safe throwing this out
[Laughter]
that might need to okay i'm going to add
more and somebody if i approach stain
remover very unlike the rest of my life
is it not going to come out and you want
to make the neurosciences look stupid
now i want you to uh is there such a
thing now i want you to take the baking
soda yes ma'am put some on your
toothbrush
and then i just want you to sort of i'm
going to use this i'm liking all the
dispensers
i was going to say gently
brush
are you implying that my vigorous
brushing is what made it worse
well
it's kind of judgy
tell you a little story about what
happens unfortunately when people
vigorously brush
that you are actually setting the stain
into the fiber why didn't you tell me
that before i'm sorry i didn't know you
were going in
but
so what you want to do is in stain
removal you would want to do the
opposite of what you think you lift
you lift and any time you go in there
like that you are just setting it in
there harder
and so you want to like hear her feel
this i don't want to feel anything
feel this
that's very soft right
buddy paw
patrol
kitty
what okay baby i need to know what the
next phase is okay then we're going to
go back to the hydrogen peroxide
and and do that see how it's changing
color
okay so back now it looks like instead
of just black sharpie it's red and blue
and then you want to get your toothbrush
in there more okay and then you want to
now try that gentle approach make love
to it you know
with my bunny paw
make love to it with your buddy paw
exactly i lose whatever game this was i
just lost well if this isn't this isn't
perfect it's not easy that you're you're
doing great and
i
i
i you will pay for the therapy session i
have about this
i i'm still dealing with a lot of red we
both are i've gotten down through the
black you know and if nothing else we've
changed the color of it
absolutely okay so here you're getting a
little vigorous i i yeah because i'm
feeling like i have nothing to lose
here's here's what happens when you have
nothing to lose okay bleach there is
always an option true story now i have
buckets of water here because what you
want to do is if you think
you know you're having fiber problems as
you're rubbing that stain all over the
place let me pour you a shot
oopsie it's okay it's white it's yeah
yeah exactly okay so um so this is where
you go okay
forget it i'm not getting anywhere and
you take your little toothbrush just a
little bit and you just start going with
the straight bleach and again still
smells like the ymca when i was a kid oh
i love that smell the bleach in the pool
smells like learning to swim okay do you
see that oh it's a magic eraser it's
going away and then see that oh wow
okay so now you're good now get it in
the water get in the water
i am not there yet
i'm not there yet i'm a little slower
with my bleaching
oh oh it's working though
i feel much better already okay so
there we go
and then
i would oh wow throw it straight
in the wash
in the water now do you see that and
back
[Applause]
[Applause]
hold your t-shirt up i mean good as new
we did it we did it
i'm proud of us you did it now i want to
do it again
beautiful and you're perfect
[Music]